nice to meet you
nice to meet you um i'm curious what do
you wish you knew
on the first day of making this movie
that you didn't know
i wished i had had a little more heads
up that there was a global pandemic
coming our way and that we were all
going to have to figure out
how to make an animated feature from our
living rooms together but apart
right and actually that leads me to
something that i was going to ask which
is um
about the editing process because often
on animated movies you go through a ton
of revisions based on
screenings you know you test the movie
in so many different ways
how did that get impacted uh like how
did that change
like learning what was working and not
working when you normally
put it in front of audiences yeah i mean
the editing process
in particular was one that took a lot of
um
problem solving to to find a process
that
got us through and we ended up doing it
all
through video like this over a digital
platform i think it was called evercast
so our editor would be remoting
into his system at the studio from home
and we would all be remoting into that
session with
to watch to to conduct an edit edit
session
and you know make cuts make revisions
make changes but
you know the the challenge of that is
that we're
trying to create a big theatrical
cinematic feature film
for a massive theater screen but we're
all reviewing
dailies and looking at edit sessions on
our laptops at home
so there's no sense of are we even
achieving the scope we need to to to
create this thing so that you know that
was
it took a lot of faith and trust in the
process
and just waiting to get back into the
theater to review these things
months later um so that you know that
was a really interesting
time to go through i'm sure
also like i said i've spoken to many
different directors who've done animated
movies
and they talk about how the film can
change so dramatically
from when you start to what people are
going to actually see did this film go
through those kinds of
massive changes or was it more like
little things that got tweaked along the
way
yeah i would say it's probably somewhere
in the middle i think because when we
all started we knew we had a really
tight deadline we from start to finish
our production was only two years in
comparison to most
animated films who have more than that
um so
we had to start out being very efficient
about our story and knowing
where our characters were going there
were there were entire scenes that were
in there at the beginning that got cut
out for
you know efficiency and storytelling
uh but for the most part i think this
one was probably pretty similar
at the start to finish than most is
there anything that you can share that
like was a big revision or a big change
that might surprise
fans there was one additional
gigantic action excitement
scene in the second act that we ended up
cutting out because it was overshadowing
the climax of our film
uh so for storytelling purposes we we
toned that one down a little
and just let act two climb and climb and
climb until
the craziness happened uh so you know it
was mostly changes like that that we
ended up making
a number of directors and they talked
about once it's been animated you can't
cut it
so how far into the process have you did
you cut something
or do you know what i mean because it
costs a lot of money to animate a move
yeah i think you know because of the
idea that we had a two-year schedule
we didn't start animating anything until
we were a hundred percent sure that it
was going to end up in that final
product
so there wasn't a you know if it was
anything
we were trimming one or two seconds off
of the beginning or ends of shots just
to make the cuts work nicer and
editorial when everything was done and
uh yeah the efficiency for us on this
project was key
i understand what do you wish more
people knew
about the way what it takes to make an
animated movie
yeah i mean i feel like that's a
question that comes up a lot and even
the difference between making a live
action movie making
versus making an animated movie it's the
amount of
involvement the director and the entire
crew
have to have as a collaborative team
from the very beginning to the very end
in every single department i mean
i think the sheer scope of the crew
that it takes to make it i think we have
something between four and 500 people in
our ends
and credits list which is a massive
undertaking
and the leadership like me and my
producer my co-director
have to have the the vision
and the stamina in order to keep all of
those people motivated and working in
the same direction towards the same goal
i think that's it's that's huge a huge
part of the job
what do you think is like something that
technology might be able to overcome
in the upcoming future to help make
animated movies even better
yeah i for me it is it's you know
probably a mix of this
evolution we've gone through a mix of
working remotely versus working in the
studio and allowing
um that flexibility
you know and it's pretty amazing even
from start to finish on this project the
platforms were we were using
were being molded and manipulated into
something that we specifically needed
for this project versus what can this
prod
what can this platform do for another
project we were working with this really
great
program called sync sketch to review our
animation dailies every day
and what that allowed was for a group of
people to all be watching the same daily
session
while fit while interacting with the
shots and doing draw overs flipping from
beginning to end or to the next sequence
so it was kind of like a real-time
working session but we were all
not in the same physical space it was i
feel like
this evolution of technology is is going
to be so cool
to watch people from all over the place
be able to collaborate
really closely on the same thing
now that actually sounds really cool and
i could see how that would make it
awesome
um i gotta stop i'm just gonna say
congrats on the movie hope it's a big
hit for you
and you get to make something again soon
thanks so much maybe next time in person
very excited